[Music]
hey
here we are once again and we are back
tuesday
september 1st august is [ __ ]
over yeah yeah even though it's still
hot out
we saw a pretty good uh free movie last
night that what was off tubey wasn't it
yeah
yeah it was good i thought it was gonna
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
and it kind of was a [ __ ] show but they
went all in on it in the best possible
yeah
it went all in on it it was kind of like
as good as velocipaster not quite as
zany as that yeah
but um but in the sense that and it was
better made than philosophers
yeah yeah i think it was but in the
sense that they
took a premise and like just ramped up
the ridiculousness and they just all
knew what they were making
it's about these two hot vampire chicks
run into some cannibals
and they kill the cannibals and then the
[ __ ] priest
and the [ __ ] from the exorcist and the
woman from [ __ ] 45
miss 45 which is a damn mutant nun with
guns
they have to fight an alien invasion
from war of the worlds that bring
alien zombies aliens when when aliens
attack people it makes the people
yeah yeah it's kind of like it's kind of
like body snatchers inside
it's everything all everything's all
mixed in the same movie
the the acting was spotty it was
but the writing was really good the
writing was really good the storytelling
was really good it's [ __ ] hilarious
i have to okay so what ended up
happening with this was that
i'm on to be and i'm looking for you
know i do a search for all the 2020 like
horror movies
and this is one that came up i picked
this one in particular just because
the sentence long description sounded
funny and also because it was only an
hour and 15 minutes long and we had like
other [ __ ] we had to watch so i was like
well this one's pretty short
and it sounds like a funny like premise
they did it right
let's watch it it's called savage
creatures did we say that
uh no it's it's got a good
uh premise production value is pretty
good
uh this is better than i was expecting
yeah the movie was not made for a whole
lot of move money and you can tell
but the edit was great it was a very
fast-paced edits it kept you in the
movie and
wanting to see what's going to happen
next uh there's a lot of [ __ ]
homages to other [ __ ] obscure movies
and you go oh okay nice talk it's
hilarious it's funny
and um they did what i recommended
which that's why i give it to my seal of
approval don't worry about this two-hour
[ __ ]
edit it down into something that's
enjoyable through the whole thing i'd
rather have a [ __ ] awesome
hour and 15 minutes than a [ __ ] up
hour and a half
you know yeah cut that [ __ ] out uh make
a short high impact and if you're gonna
go
if you have a low budget movie and it's
going to be crazy
you make it even more crazy yeah just
make it as crazy as make it as
crazy as [ __ ] possible and that's
what they did so the movie stood
stood out and it had a good sign it had
a good score yeah
this was actually written directed and
edited i think by the same guy
richard lowry wasn't he did a good job
richard you did a good job
i yeah this movie was like a hell of a
lot of fun that's how you do it
like i said when when i first started
like i said i picked it because
i was like oh that sounds kind of funny
and it's only an hour and 15 minutes
long because we have other [ __ ] we gotta
do
and so i put it on and like i was
watching the opening credits
and like in the opening credits they
kind of showed like some of the scenes
from the movie like behind the openings
it was all red and stuff
yeah and i'm watching and i'm kind of
going um this is going to be like ouija
shark level
but actually when i was watching it i
was like oh this is actually much better
than i was expecting like the
cinematography was actually decent like
the way the shots were set up was really
decent
so it's like it's much you can tell that
it's like a micro budget movie
but it you can tell that it's done by
somebody that knows what they're doing
yeah you know it was down right it was
shot very competently
where it's taking place is very
interesting it's uh somewhere out in the
[ __ ] it looks like a wet summer like
colorado or utah or somewhere
there's snow happening uh it gives you a
very kind of a small
town out in the middle of nowhere
[ __ ] feel uh so the town is right
um the interior shots are good
where they where they shot it is is is
good
uh the girls who are the main characters
the two hot vampire chicks um their
acting is not great but it doesn't
matter it fits with the [ __ ] tone of
the movie
and they seem to get better as the movie
goes on kind of like the thing was shot
in order it might have been
they seemed a little wooden at the
beginning maybe it was me i don't know
maybe it took me a while to warm up to
them but it seemed
their acting seemed to be a little
wooden at the beginning but as it went
they got better
um the [ __ ] priest that comes in
knocks it out of the [ __ ] part he
doesn't know what actually he commits
he commits to this [ __ ] all right this
should have been
this should have been [ __ ] what was
his name anthony hopkins
right it was like he should have played
this role and he's doing an anthony
hopkins
but he's an anthony hopkins over the top
anthony hopkins
that doesn't know if he's doing an irish
accent or an english accent but
[ __ ] it you know what they're all the
same well you know what you know what's
funny about that though because like
when we were watching that scene
and then um and it was really funny but
then like at the end like during the end
credits they showed that they shot takes
yeah and they showed him like doing a
scene and then he stopped and he said
something like what the [ __ ] voice am i
doing
yeah yeah yeah he was aware of the time
he was aware of what it was maybe the
director's just like just go with it
just go with it yeah it's so they're all
the same
[ __ ] it's it's just added it
attitude because the the movie's [ __ ]
winking at you and being tongue in cheek
through the whole thing it's just trying
to give you
a pleasant experience and i wasn't even
drinking i
should have been drinking for this movie
it probably definitely needed needed
yeah we didn't even have any drinks last
night it was still good kind of bummed
out
it had been even better it'd have been
even better if i was drunk
but uh it was just this is how you make
a low budget micro
like i said this is in the same spirit
as velocipaster like i said it's not as
crazy as that one it's like more
competently done than that one
yeah but velocifaster though man there
were some decisions that they made with
the camera work
yeah that oh it was deliberate it was so
deliberate but only an
expert would have done some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that's true
that's true only when that guy fell on
the field and they're ah
the camera's following me it's
definitely by hand and [ __ ]
it was hilarious but i think this one
was like in the same spirit is that
because we use velocity
that's kind of like the yardstick
nowadays for that type of movie yeah
where it's like where it's winking at
you and it's funny and like everyone's
in on the joke but it's
but not in an obnoxious way because i
feel like some horror comedies go too
far in that direction like look how
clever we are
look how funny we are yeah and this one
didn't really do that it was just
like more naturalistically funny just
like the whole situation of it was funny
just like philosopher it was just like
you know the the whole like premise of
the movie is so
ridiculous yeah that you don't really
need the people in it to be
ridiculous on top of that because just
the situation is ridiculous yeah and
he's winking at you you know on certain
scenes where they're in the bathtub the
two girls in the bad time they're like
you've seen [ __ ] you've seen the
hunger
you know that's what you know what i
that's what made me be like dude
director of this movie i love you
because there are so many horror
comedies that homage
other movies yeah but they usually
homage
um better known ones yeah like the
exorcist or evil dead or something like
that
yeah i think this is the first
low-budget horror movie that i've seen
that
referenced the hunger the hugger yeah
there was
two chicks in a bathtub full of blood
and that schubert piece that's
become indelibly like attached to the
hunger for me because it played so many
times during the movie
and you know them just like saying
they're like reminiscing each other my
dear
the good old days of like being vampires
and stuff like that and it was just so
hunger i was just like dude i love you
so much right now i'm just like
who does that nobody does that and then
when when the [ __ ] when the nun came in
with the [ __ ] 45s and [ __ ] well i
don't think there were 45s with the two
pistols
and she was mute and they pointed that i
was like oh yeah
45 reference because that was you know
there's a bunch of little ones and then
like the
the radio the radio announcement and
then the old-fashioned way
and it's like oh okay war of the worlds
we got you bro
war of the worlds and it's just right
down to the [ __ ] war of the world's
[ __ ] life and it kind of
like the way the aliens looked like when
they were coming down from space like
that yeah practical expects too
yeah it could have been like face
huggers but to me it looked
more like the bat aliens in it conquered
the world
that roger corman one with beverly
garland and lee van cleef was in there
yeah it was funny is that they were
flying in [ __ ] v
formation slowly over the [ __ ] earth
and you go okay yeah
light just like from war of the worlds
the damn boomerang spaceships
you know i just i liked that it had
homages but not really obvious ones
and also not like so overt that they're
just like
you got to know movies look how clever
we are you gotta know movies know what
they're talking about
yes on some of them and like i said that
hunger one i was just like that that
just made me all warm and fuzzy inside
yeah but um yeah so the whole like i
said
that i read the description of this i'm
like okay that sounds pretty funny
the whole like [ __ ] premise of this
we start out with a dude
like a kind of a chubby dude named darby
and his mom
liz i thought they were like married
couple at first but i guess they were
mother and son
yeah it was all incestuous yeah it was
like yeah it was pretty weird um
and so they there's all you're not gonna
put any spoilers in this no
no you're gonna go through the whole
premise no i'm just saying they pick up
somebody
you know they're they're cannibals like
i said you find out that they're
cannibals like in the first couple
minutes of the movie
then they pick up these two girls turns
out the two girls are vampires
and then there's just and then there's
an alien attack and then there's like
[ __ ] aliens make zombies it's just
it's craziness and then there's like
this [ __ ] over-the-top priest and the
mute
nun that comes in and everyone's like
battling the aliens
and the vampires are really pretty much
the main characters
i mean we kind of start out with
cannibals but then when once the
vampires come
on the scene the two of them are pretty
much
yeah they're the big characters the
protagonists the heroes of the movie i
guess
yeah bunch of bunch of cool [ __ ] hams
yeah i liked uh the fact that they had
some decent
creature effects yeah right they cut the
creature apart it was like on the level
of like uh
you know from beyond or or reanimator
you know they're cutting into the [ __ ]
and there's some love crafty and [ __ ]
that happens in there
uh the priest goes on about a bunch of
lovecraftian stuff
you'll enjoy it you'll enjoy it pineal
glands and
it's just you know and how that was what
where the seed of the soul was
that's what the zombies were eating the
strength of the movie was competently
shot
and it's good storytelling excellent
script a lot good humor
it's not yeah it's very good it's very
you said it's very good nature it's a
good nature good natured
um you know they knew how ridiculous and
they're just like they just keep piling
it on and piling it on
but not like to not to a zany extent
where you're just like oh my god just
knock it off but it was just like i'm 51
man that's the kind of movies we grew up
with
yeah you know that's the way it's just
fun it's a fun movie yeah
that's the way reanimator was all the
reanimator
sequels uh from beyond uh that was
that's that tone
yeah i mean and yeah it was a yeah it
was a horror movie yeah it had gore
in it yeah it would trip you the [ __ ]
out it was funny though also
yeah yeah not so that's you know that's
just like the evil dead it was it was
kind of funny
yeah you know that's kind of took the
edge off of it
because if [ __ ] was too serious then you
end up going
you end up going you know kind of like
the rob zombie direction where
you kind of feel bad about watching it
like devil's rejects or something you
know
i like that too it's just not as an
enjoyable experience for me
as something that's like yeah it's yeah
it's kind of like different i like all
kinds of horror movies yeah but um
yeah there are some that it's like you
see them one time and you're like yeah i
don't think i need to watch that you
don't need to see it again right
or or you have to be in a particular
mood to watch it because you know it's
going to make you
kind of feel real bad yeah you know what
i mean which is how i feel about
hereditary as much as i loved that movie
it's like i'm almost like anxious about
watching it again because i don't want
to feel like [ __ ] like i did after
watching that movie before this summer
would be like that
because yeah because it was just like so
dread inducing and it just made me feel
so terrible that it's just like which
like i said that's what it was supposed
in a way
joker's almost like that yeah like yeah
like it's
it's about to see once but you know
that's about like i don't know if i want
to see that one again
yeah because it like puts you in a bad
emotional place which like i said that's
what it's supposed
to do right but it doesn't really like
review yeah not this one this one's
this this one is just like pure
entertainment
uh fun very very good natured movie
uh it's not trying to shove any kind of
[ __ ] weird agendas down your throat
or anything it's just an honest movie
they're just going to entertain you
that's what it does yeah and like
and we've said this a million times like
when especially since we've been doing
these like kind of
micro budget stuff that turns up on
tubey all the time yeah there's good
movies on there too it's just
you have to there's a lot of these on
there too but um you know some of these
uh some of these we've started watching
them and they were just like so cheap
and like so
incompetent that you can't even sit
through them yeah but this one every now
and then you find
like a little gem yeah you know like
when you're looking through these and
this is definitely one of those yeah
another thing that's funny is that
there's an attempt to brand the movie
and there's an attempt for a possible
sequel which that was that was the way
to go
you could go with this and uh along the
lines of say like phantasm
were the main characters oh yeah where
it could be like kind of a roadmap
did you notice that yeah they had both
lived and then they were thinking about
how they were gonna survive the [ __ ]
apocalypse and this and that that would
you could you could make a sequel you
could make mini sequels kind of like
and this did kind of feel like a
labor of love this movie and that and so
was
phantasm so i could see that maybe you
can make several of these
if that dude who make [ __ ] burdemic
can make several movies
why can't this dude make it i was saying
if the dude that made camp blood
is up to [ __ ] the eighth one yeah
yeah and that's like
a terrible terrible movie yeah
this i mean if there was any justice in
the world
this should be a franchise yeah i would
watch it i would
watch every single one just by no
stretch of the the imagination
is a fantastic high budget movie it just
isn't yeah it's like a tiny budget
it's just a very enjoyable well-made
cheap movie that has a lot of elements
of [ __ ] show in it
and you it has to be a [ __ ] show yeah
if it wasn't a [ __ ] show you wouldn't be
watching it
it's just the right mixture look man
evil dead was a [ __ ] show evil dead one
was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
evil dead two was a [ __ ] show people did
three was a [ __ ] [ __ ] show that's why
you were watching that [ __ ]
so he knew he knows what he's doing yeah
yeah and like this is very hard to get
right
and we talked about this when we were
talking about philosopher i said you
know i feel like
you know with the advent of cheap
filmmaking yeah you know one of the
things you can do is like if you're
gonna if you don't have that much money
to make a
film then you need to make like you need
to think of a premise that everyone's
gonna talk about so everyone's gonna
watch your movie
right so it's going to say it's got to
be enjoyable yeah but
i feel like sometimes when people are
making those movies all they think of is
the premise and they don't really put
much thought into the actual movie
yeah and like i said it's kind of hard
and you know
because i feel like they want to coast
on that but see this movie didn't do
that
no it kind it lived up to the [ __ ] it's
constantly serving the audience with the
next [ __ ] gag or the next [ __ ]
wink or the [ __ ] next [ __ ] homage
and
the story is unfolding there's no
slow spots in the movie yeah it just
flips right along it's just
it it's better to clip that 15 or 20
minutes of filler out of that movie
and get yourself a good good solid hour
and 15 minutes
and really for the modern viewer
an hour and 15 minutes is if it's if
it's action-packed is there plenty
for a movie the modern need to be longer
yeah like i said it depends on the story
but it's like modern attention span can
handle about an hour and a half
hour and 15 minutes because you're
competing against
little [ __ ] mobile devices and all
kinds of other stuff
shorter for a movie like this is better
if it's a good
hour and 15 minutes of solid packed
entertainment
hell yeah yeah because it doesn't work
welcome out well like we said
velocipaster is only about an hour long
yeah but it didn't need to be longer
than no and it was just the person it
was a quality
one hour of entertainment chock full
of nuts
well that was like okay blood machines
each one of those episodes is short
but [ __ ] it's just full of stuff i
think that was only 45 minutes 50
minutes all together all together
you didn't need to really be any longer
you know now i want to see another one
yeah see what i mean yeah leave them
believe people wanting more
right you now i want to see another one
now you can have like a little series of
little 15-minute [ __ ] shorts
yeah like that i think that that plays
out well in the modern
world well the thing about the premise
of savage creatures in particular is
that it's so sprawling because like
every monster they're like hey you want
vampires hey you want cannibals hey you
want zombies you want aliens you want
this that the other you want to kill or
none
you want this that the other so they put
all of it in there so there's like so
much room for like
universe expansion if you really wanted
to do that you could explore lots of
different ways that was my takeaway with
the road trip
premise at the ending of the movie i
went oh okay
like phantasm yeah that's what that's
how i
so that's just another kind of like
another homage
yeah like phantasm it's gonna become
like it could become a road trip movie
yeah yeah even if they could so big i
give it a thumbs up big thumbs up
i do too i had i had a [ __ ] blast
with this movie like i said
a lot of times you click on some of
these movies on toby that are like
really cheap and you're just like it
looked like it was filmed in somebody's
house and they don't even know how to do
lighting or anything but it's like
this one was actually a a very large
pleasant surprise because this was a lot
of fun
and they just had a great time with it
i'd actually buy this movie i'd buy it
yeah and like i said if they want to
make more yep i'd watch them
yeah [ __ ] sell them things as a [ __ ]
dv as a blu-ray
set yeah yeah yeah whole little uh it'd
be fun
franchise there and just i would keep
the same tone
same fun tone the way the way uh
phantasm did and yeah yeah totally
but yeah this is uh on to be for free
right now i've got an hour and fifteen
minutes to kill
you get yourself some cocktails or
whatever
yeah and just sit down and watch the
madness yeah
because it's a lot of fun it doesn't
could this could be like a
this could be a double feature with
velocipaster because velocimaster's on
tv too as well you can slip free
entertainment look at that what a time
to be alive you guys yeah
all right so we're gonna wrap this up
because we've been going on for half an
hour and like i said we probably got
other [ __ ] we gotta do
but we will be back with another either
matinee or side tracks tomorrow same bat
time same bat channel
we'll talk to you guys tomorrow bye